moi je la vois à 24 ans elle partage sa
vie amoureuse avec son conjoint à
Chicoutimi lundi elle s'est tournée vers
un pharmacien lorsqu'elle a craint une
grossesse non désirée j'avais un peu la
boule dans l'estomac je me sentais mal
je me sentais vraiment jugée aux gens
Coutu le pharmacie appelé sa conscience
religieuse pour lui refuser la
contraception aura d'urgence aussi
appelée la pilule du lendemain je pense
pas que c'est au pharmacien de nous
faire sentir comme ça que c'est nos
décisions c'est c'est à moi de 37
décisions là c'est pas à lui c'est mon
corps à moi comment je me sens je suis
outré en fait une brèche préoccupante
pour la santé reproductive des femmes
parce que la contraception d'urgence
doit être prise dans un délai de 12 à 72
heures après une relation sexuelle les
valeurs religieuses d'une personne
je travaille en pharmacie à notre sens
devrait pas avoir pressément sur le
libre choix de la personne et la liberté
de choisir si et quand elle veut des
enfants
qui ont besoin de traitement de VIH que
besoin de traitement contre des ITS je
trouve ça vraiment déplorable les
professionnels de la santé dont les
pharmaciens peuvent bel et bien refuser
d'octroyer des soins en vertu de la
Charte des droits et libertés de la
personne au niveau des médecins qui
refuse de pratiquer des avortements par
exemple ou la mystère à mourir aussi ces
objecteurs de conscience sont néanmoins
la responsabilité de référer
adéquatement les femmes à un autre
pharmacien pour leur assurer des soins
adéquats fondamentalement il faut éviter
qu'on en vienne à placer ce fardeau là
sur les épaules d'une patiente qui a
besoin de ce traitement là dans un délai
rapproché il faut pas qu'on s'en lave
les mains le pharmacien aux gens Coutu
de Chicoutimi a admis avoir refusé de
donner la pilule du lendemain par passer
tout en déclinant notre demande
d'entrevue je me suis jamais sentie même
de ma vie en ce moment aux Etats-Unis
ils ont perdu droit à l'avortement puis
sa première fois que je me sentais comme
bloquée quelque part chez le bébé on est
au Québec c'est quoi le rapport même si
elle a été référée à une pharmacie
avoisinante son expérience lui aura
laissé un arrière-goût amer ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal